How powerful can scientists make a computer chip?
By the turn of the millennium, experts said that tiny chips...
...packed more and more densely with hundreds of millions of transistors would generate too much heat.
So scientists at Intel developed technologies that enable a microprocessor to do more.
Well, the Core i7 is a pretty radical redesign.
In fact, it's one of the biggest changes in the way the PC works in quite a while.
So the things we've done are kind of open it up so that it can be fed...
...open the processor up so that you can feed it with the data better.
Intel did this with a number of innovations such as:...
...moving the memory controller onto the chip to achieve higher memory bandwidth,...
...turbo boost technology, which increases frequency when the processor detects it has available power headroom,...
...and an integrated power gate, which shuts off power to those cores which aren't in use.
Scientists like Intel Fellow Glenn Hinton say the technology has increased performance and energy efficiency.
The guys in the power management team did a lot of work to reduce the overall...
...and actively manage the power so that if one core is running we get a lot of power to that sort,...
...run really high-performance, that's turbo mode.
And if all the cores are working, we adjust the frequency and voltage to make everything work well.
And so, that whole very active power management went way beyond anything we've done on any of our previous chips.
At Intel's lab in Silicon Valley, engineers test the Core i7 in a variety of hardware and software configurations especially in high-end gaming.
I manage a group of guys that our job is to look at the products that Intel is going to be producing and try to explain the benefits...
...in terms that people can understand, that they can relate to things they really do with the PC.
So instead of just talking about this thing is 50 percent faster, we try to find ways to say, "Okay, what can I do with that 50 percent?"
So what Regina is doing here is she's actually going in and playing this game that recently was released.
And she'll try out a variety of different settings, whether it's the screen resolution or the quality settings in the game.
So whenever a new game is launched, she has to spend just hours in here.
It's a terrible job, going through and playing that game over and over and over again until she comes up with the right settings.
It's hard.
And the right test.
Francois Piednoel is testing the Core i7 here on an Intel motherboard.
So far, he has observed bandwidth that is two times higher than on a previous quad-core microprocessor.
So you got the processor, you got the board and for six months you try to figure out where's the problem. Here or here?
And it's a ping-pong between the architecture team. And I'm sitting in the middle,...
...taking from the right hand to the left hand and trying to exchange.
We've got a lot of smart people working on this; it's a huge team.
This is the lab where we're doing a lot of the functional validation of Nehalem, making sure that it's a good, robust part as we launch it...
...and bring it to consumers. We also check our performance and labs just like this up here in Oregon...
...as we have our architecture design and validation teams all co-located here.
The design of the Core i7, code-named "Nehalem" in the lab, involved thousands of engineers in places such as...
...Oregon, California and Arizona, and in Malaysia and Costa Rica.
Rani Borkar oversaw the development of the microprocessor across Intel's many organizations,...
...handling tasks like architecture and design, manufacturing, testing and debugging.
Of course we have structures and over time we've learned to make these structures...
...better and better so that it really progresses very seamlessly.
Because the timelines, one thing which is constant is the timeline,...
...when you're going to deliver and what you said you will deliver.
Intel delivers chips on its Tick Tock model.
The Tick represents advances and processed technologies such as from 65 nanometer to 45,...
...which was Penryn in 2007. The Tock is a new micro architecture, in this case "Nehalem."
With the Tock processor, we get the chance to overhaul complete micro architecture as well as the platform.
The internal of the core has been changed significantly for added performance as well as for better energy efficiency.
So one of the fun things we've been doing even on the previous projects is from an individual contributor's role,...
...when their piece of the design is done and what we locally call "putting it in the freezer",...
...you go and give them a gold balloon.
I've been working on Nehalem since 2003 and so when we eventually get silicon,...
...one of the key moments is the first silicon in the lab...
...and getting it to actually boot a real operating system and run real applications.
People compare it to a parent, seeing their baby for the first time.
It's both the design engineers, the circuit technology folks, the circuit designers, the validation people,...
...architects, all of the design team; it's a huge project, a huge team.
This is rocket science, this is hard stuff.
This is our baby, our new baby.
This is our new baby, this is the Intel Core i7 microprocessor.
This is the fastest processor on the planet.